guys Jimmy Fallon has a question because
he's very protective of Drew listen to
this question and answer it how you wish
this is Drew's friend and co-star Jimmy
Fallon here's your question Drew loves
music she's dated musicians she likes
creative guys show her your creative
Side by making up a song on the spot
about where you take her for a first
date Jimmy you kind of
I really did a number on these guys
that's a good little question it's a
very good question number four uh what
do you go ahead I have a guitar here can
I can I use it right ahead man who's
ready oh my God you're prepared I didn't
know this would happen but I always have
a guitar next to me so it goes like this
[Music]
a trip to Saint Barts
three days on the beach
get your passport ready cause our
Pilot's name is Freddy
we'll have separate rooms
look at this guy cause I'm not a goon
three days in
this don't worry
no man wow Japan
so you'll be okay
you'll have a great time and maybe
expand your mind
Jesus Saint parts
three days in Saint Barts
three days in Saint Barts wow you really
did I thought
impressive number four number three
where's your song what the hell was that
I didn't know God damn it this is so
unfair
where's your saxophone I don't know
where Saint Barts is I don't know
by the way that was the free bird of
dating songs
number three go ahead not a musical
person at all let's I'm gonna try and
just clap a little bit
gonna go to the Waverly Diner we're
gonna have Club chips and fries and sit
we're gonna have a Coke we're going to
walk down the street I'll walk you home
and we will also text when we get poem I
don't know how to write a song I know
there's a bridge that's about it I love
that song I love you know what that's my
kind of date
extremes between the two songs I love it
yeah I remember my tax bracket
Bachelor number two uh do you have oh I
see you have a guitar also yeah Drew
Barrymore's lullaby marriage
[Music]
walk around the city
Escape finding Hearts to gape
laughing as time flies by
that's all I got maybe that number one
what about drew some sort of song that
Jimmy Fallon suggests might win her over
is there anything you can invent I I
don't think so but I I could definitely
um I could I could push her toward
Bachelor four
idea by the way your answer was perfect
fair enough